senator cruz joins us now it's
interesting uh because trump also left
them secure borders energy independence
we didn't have inflation uh we had low
gas prices so that is one big lie and
i'm glad you called him out on it
senator
never in my lifetime senator cruz that i
think we'd abandon
americans behind enemy lines when we had
months and months and months observing
and watching with our intelligence
community this is not an intelligence
failure i've been told repeatedly by
many sources
telling them they're on the march we
could have safely extracted and
withdrawn every american every afghan
ally and all our military equipment
this is beyond incompetence to me your
thoughts
well i think that's exactly right this
this is the worst foreign policy
disaster in a generation and it was
really two things that drove it one
radical ideology these guys are naive
they think they're in a college faculty
lounge they think the taliban wants to
be welcomed and embraced at at the un
coffee bar
and and number two manifest incompetence
they combine the two uh with a series of
decisions that were just disastrous
abandoning the bagram airfield it has no
justification a hundred years from now
sean at the war college they're going to
teach abandoning bagram two secure
airstrips a secure perimeter protected
from terrorist attacks and we gave it to
the taliban moving our evacuation
instead to the kabul international
airport a dense urban environment
controlled by the taliban
that cost the lives of 13 service men
and women they didn't have to die if
we'd been at bagram there's a very good
chance that secure perimeter would have
kept them alive this was incompetence
and it was radical ideology and i'll
tell you sean
blinken had two admissions today that
were really significant number one i
asked him flat out is it true that the
biden administration gave the taliban a
list of americans and a list of afghans
we wanted out and after he hemmed and
hawed he finally said yes we gave them a
list
that is terrifying and it may very well
have functioned as a kill list putting
them in harm's way and then secondly i
asked him if it was true the reports
that there had been a number of afghan
refugees afghan men
who came with little girls little girls
who they claimed were their wives were
they facing child
brides of little girls being sexually
assaulted being raped by grown taliban
men again blinking said yes the u.s
state department was effectively
trafficking child predators and children
in both instances he refused to answer
the follow-up question how many names
did you give the taliban how many
children are being sexually assaulted
while the biden administration is
bringing them to u.s soil
i i am aghast hearing you describe it
senator but they keep referring to the
taliban as professional and
business-like professional and
business-like
uh how could they not understand these
are terrorists they're now out there
we're chronicling beheadings we're
chronicling torture and and literally
ripping nails out of people's hands
before shooting them in the head and
hunting people down and beating women in
the streets and child brides it's only
the beginning and no no no no
affirmation we they still don't know
how many americans and how many green
card holders and how many of our allies
did they abandoned because they
abandoned them and many will die senator
those people you're describing will die
they will be murdered brutally
there are at least hundreds of americans
that they abandoned behind enemy lines
it may be thousands there are thousands
of legal permanent residents in america
green card holders that they abandoned
and there may well be tens of thousands
of afghans who risked their lives
helping us who they abandoned behind
enemy lines and many of them tragically
face the risk of torture or death or
both senator you raised the issue about
about all the billions and billions of
dollars of american military might left
behind our equipment
and he actually tried to make the case
that it will not be used
against their neighbors it will not be
used against people that they deem to be
their enemy
uh please tell me
how does somebody
how do i say this nicely there's no nice
way to say how does how can somebody be
that ignorant
that stupid that naive and that dumb
to not believe because we already know
what's happening with the equipment
now that that's exactly right and he's
repeating partisan talking points
unfortunately the biden administration
they're playing the blame game and their
talking point is it's trump's fault it's
trump's fault one democrat at the
hearing today said we should have
hearings on george w bush that it's not
even just trump's fault it's bush's
fault i mean they're reaching for
anything except for the actual
commander-in-chief that screwed this up
and and i gotta say when blinking today
said well yes some 80 billion dollars of
american uh weaponry and and vehicles
fell into the hands of the taliban but
it will not be used against us or our
allies what utter nonsense 33 blackhawk
helicopters last i checked the
terrorists didn't start with 33
blackhawks and i'll tell you what may be
actually the biggest game changer
because their point on on the vehicles
is that they don't have the equipment to
maintain them that may be right so it
may be in relatively short order they
can't keep them in the air although with
with the chinese or russians they could
get assistance in helping maintain those
vehicles but but what might be the
biggest game changers there are over 10
000 night vision goggles that that that
the taliban now has if you talk to the
refugees of afghanistan that was really
the game changer that we owned the night
that we could see at night we could take
out the terrorists and they couldn't
they were blind at night they now have
american night vision goggles and
americans will die because joe biden
allowed the taliban to get those night
vision goggles senator thanks for being
with us